[موسيقى]
بالطبع لهذه الاتفاقيه والتي تعرف ايضا
باتفاقيه البحر الاسود اهميه كبيره نتيجه
لان اوكرانيا تصدر حوالي 30% من انتاج
الحبوب على مستوى العالم لاسيما القمح كما
انها تعتبر المصدر رقم خمسه في
عالميا في من حيث الكميات هذه
الاتفاقيه تظهر اهميتها بشده ايضا عندما
نعرف انه في اعقاب الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وبعد ذلك بشهر واحد فقط كان هناك
20 مليون طن من الحبوب قد خزنت في الموانئ
الاوكرانيه المختلفه ولم يتم الافراج عنها
وبعدما تم الاتفاق على ذلك تم الافراج على
هذه الاتفاقيه وبالتالي رجعت الاسعار مره
اخرى الى مستوياتها ما قبل الحرب تقريبا
لا سيما بعد تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه لاكثر من
مره خلال الشهور الماضيه
لا شك انسحاب روسيا من هذه الاتفاقيه يشكل
تهديدا كبيرا للامن الغذائي العالمي كله
نتيجه ليس فقط للدول الفقيره وانما ايضا
للدول الغنيه رغم ان هذه الدول الغنيه
تتمتع بنوع ما من انواع الاكتفاء الذاتي
وبنسب لا يستهان بها من هذا الاكتفاء الا
اننا نستطيع القول ان ارتفاع الاسعار
العالمي الذي سينتج عن انسحاب روسيا من
هذه الاتفاقيه سيؤثر على الجميع شرقا
وغربا سيكون تضخم الملتهب حاليا في كل دول
العالم وفي دول الاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك هو
احد اهم المشكلات التي ستواجه الاقتصاد
العالمي
والاقتصاد الاوروبي وسيضغط بشده على الدول
الفقيره خلال الفتره القادمه
انا اعتقد ان البدائل انا اوكرانيا بدا
المحدوده للغايه ولان الصادرات الاوكرانيه
من الحبوب وفي مقدمتها القمح تشكل نسبه لا
يمكن ان يستهان بها من ايرادات الاقتصاد
الاوكراني فان منع تصدير هذه الحبوب لن
يمني فقط المزارعين الاوكران بخسائر فادحه
ولكنه ايضا سيمني مجمل الاقتصادي
الاوكراني بخسائر فادحه اما البدائل امام
الدول المستورده فنحن امام يعني نستطيع ان
نقول ان الفتره الزمنيه ربما تقاس بالاجل
القصير المتوسط في الاجل القصير اعتقد ان
البدائل والخيارات محدوده ومحدوده للغايه
امام الدول المستورده لا سيما الفقيره
الفقيره منها حتى في تلك الاتفاقيات التي
يمكن ان او الاسواق التي يمكن ان تتفق
معاها مع هذه الدول ان توافر المال الكافي
للشراء في الاجل المتوسط اعتقد ان هذه
الدول يجب ان نتعلم الدرس وك فى ما حدث
سابقا وما يحدث لاحقا من هذه الازمات ان
يعطينا دروسا كثيره
وبالتالي يجب ان تطور هذه الدول من
قدراتها وانكاناتها في الانتاج وفي مقدمته
الانتاج الزراعي